- Trading platform Robinhood
- And one of the most highly
anticipated IPOs of the year
- That's a big deal
for the retail investor
but it could also come
with some big risks.
- [Narrator] Last year,
millions of investors traded
on the brokerage app Robinhood.
They were part of a trend.
Since 2020, individual
investors bought billions
of dollars in equities, driven by the rise
in no-fee trading apps with
Robinhood leading the way.
- Robinhood, when it came onto the scene,
really upended the industry.
- We believe that the more
people that have access
to the markets and can
start investing earlier
the better off our economy will be.
- [Narrator] After a
year of dramatic growth,
Robinhood filed for its IPO on July 1st.
But the filing comes
as the brokerage faces
a collision course with
regulators, including a new
Securities and Exchange
Commission chairman
over a controversial
practice that Robinhood uses
to generate most of its revenue.
Here's how Robinhood
went from startup to IPO
in less than a decade and why it's facing
so much turmoil as it
gears up to go public.
In the '90s, brokerages
like E*Trade and Ameritrade
started offering online trading
services which helped open
up the stock market to retail investors.
But it was expensive.
- [Spokesman] Internet trade
for $8, Touch-Tone trade...
- [Narrator] Trading fees
could add up to hundreds
or even thousands of dollars a year.
- That was one of the reason why we saw
relatively muted levels
of individual investors
in the market.
- [Narrator] Caitlin
McCabe reports on Robinhood
and retail investing for
the Wall Street Journal.
- It was cost prohibitive
to try to be trading
all the time with these fees.
- [Narrator] That was the case until 2015
when Robinhood released its trading app.
- From the very beginning,
our mission has been
to democratize the financial system.
- [Narrator] This is Robinhood
co-founder, Baiju Bhatt.
- And for us, this isn't a
headline, it's not a gimmick
or a billboard ad, it's the central reason
why we started the company.
- [Narrator] To attract new
investors, Robinhood offered
features that made
investing more accessible.
It was one of the earliest brokerages
to offer no-fee trading.
It was also a pioneer in
fractional share trading.
- So suddenly, you could buy
$10 of Amazon or $50 of Amazon.
You could just buy, basically,
a slice of that stock
and it just made it much
easier for investors
to access the market in that way.
- [Narrator] But price
wasn't the only thing
keeping retail investors
out of the market.
- So it was just really
intimidating to try to trade
and to try to figure out charts
and to understand what was
happening in the market.
- [Narrator] Robinhood also
experimented with features
aimed at keeping people engaged.
When users would log on to the app
and place their first trade,
it used to rain confetti,
stock numbers turned like slot machines,
and some of its messages
to investors used emojis.
- And it was just a very
inviting app, it was very fun.
They were just very
kind of on the forefront
of trying to invite that
Millennial crowd into trading.
And I think it worked, I think
that's part of the reason
why Millennials liked the app.
- [Narrator] Robinhood's
user base grew quickly
which caught the attention
of its competition.
By 2019, major brokerages
like Charles Schwab
and TD Ameritrade had adopted
zero commission trading, as well.
- It was just recognition of kind of what
Robinhood had built and
the market share that
it had amassed and that
kind of was the genesis
of this new trading era that we see today.
- [Narrator] And then in early
2020, the COVID-19 pandemic
took hold of the world.
- We are looking at another
day of extreme volatility.
Stocks opened just moments ago
with the DOW down more than 600 point.
- I think with the market
volatility, a lot of people said
I think this is a good time for me
to try to get into the market
and that's where we've
really seen this explosion
of activity from individual
investors ever since.
- [Narrator] According to its IPO filing,
Robinhood counted 18 million
users with funded accounts
at the end of March
2021 and the brokerage's
first quarter revenue more than
quadrupled to $522 million.
But as Robinhood has grown,
so has criticism that
some of the app's features,
the very ones that help
make it successful could cause problems
for inexperienced investors.
Critics said the app's
interface which made it fun
and easy to use actually gamified trading
and put inexperienced investors at risk.
- Trading's a challenging business.
- [Narrator] Larry Tabb is
a financial markets analyst
who has studied market
structure for over 25 years.
- You're competing not only with some
of the largest investors in the world,
but you're trading with some of the guys
with the biggest computers
and the fastest data feeds
and the most sophisticated analytics.
It's really difficult
to continually beat them
day in and day out.
- [Narrator] Over the
past year, Robinhood has
also faced criticism over
how it makes its money
and how it previously
communicated that with investors.
In December 2020, Robinhood
agreed to pay $65 million
to settle claims that it
didn't sufficiently disclose
its business deals with
high-speed trading firms.
And then there was GameStop.
- Outrage erupting in this wild
and expensive battle that's
playing out between Wall
Street heavyweights,
small investors, and these
popular stock trading apps.
- [Narrator] In January 2021,
Robinhood came under scrutiny
after it restricted users
from buying GameStop
as the company's share price surged.
The trading blackout caused some investors
to lose out on potential gains.
About 50 class-action lawsuits,
investigations by regulators,
and multiple hearings with
members of Congress followed.
Here's Robinhood CEO speaking
with the House Committee
on financial services.
- Despite the unprecedented
market conditions in January,
at the end of the day, what
happened is unacceptable to us.
To our customers, I'm
sorry and I apologize.
- [Narrator] During the
hearings, lawmakers scrutinized
Robinhood's use of a
financial practice called
payment for order flow
which allows the brokerage
to route customer orders through
high-speed trading firms.
According to Robinhood's
IPO filing, the company made
around 81% of its first quarter
revenue from this practice.
Payment for order flow
has raised red flags
with the SEC's new Chairman, Gary Gensler.
- This inherent conflict is there
and whether we can address
it enough through disclosure
or it sort of implicates the
broader market structure.
And I've asked staff to think about that
- [Narrator] Gensler is
reviewing payment for order flow
which could have implications
for the future of Robinhood
and no-fee trading, in general.
- This is part and parcel of Robinhood
how they make money, so it
will be really interesting
to see if Gensler decides to
be a one-man wrecking crew
and really radically
reshift how the economics
of the retail brokerage business.
- [Narrator] Robinhood has faced
other regulatory issues, as well.
In June, the brokerage agreed
to pay nearly $70 million
to resolve allegations
that it misled customers,
approved ineligible traders
for risky strategies,
and didn't supervise
technology that failed
and locked millions out of trading.
According to its IPO
filing, Robinhood continues
to face a number of regulatory inquiries.
Still, some industry veterans
say Robinhood will survive
the SEC's review even if
regulations are imposed.
(soft electronic music)